okay it's really really ugly and it's
really really bad what is not clear is
whether it is really really racial ben
shapiro
is an american journalist who has made
his claim to fame by arguing with
college students on uneven platforms he
lets him speak for a little bit and then
he has a crowd a roomful of supporters
he humiliates them they're forced to run
away and then he seems like the hero
this is not a good debater this is not
an intellectual this is not an academic
this is not a contributor to the
discourse this is just someone who has
been able to manipulate yes manipulate
certain circumstances in college arenas
to try and make himself build himself
prop himself up to be something which
he's not when he was confronted by
Andrew Neil in a famous debate last year
he was thoroughly humiliated actually to
the extent whereby he actually had to
flee from the debate you know I'm not
inclined to continue an interview with a
person is badly motivated as you as an
interviewer so I think we're done here I
appreciate your time all right well we
thank you for your time and for showing
that anger is not part of American
political discourse now mr. Shapiro will
say goodbye which shows us this man is
not a debater he's not an intellectual
he's not well researched she's not even
probably well-read he's a guy who speaks
fast who thinks that by speaking fast
people will not get what he says yes and
unpack it yeah and look at all the
contradictions in way he says having
said that ben shapiro is also known for
his opposition to muslims and black
people in america he would be shocked to
know what this ben shapiro has to say
about george freud's situation ben
shapiro doesn't believe that George
Floyd was killed for a racial reason
let's hear what he has to say
it's really really ugly and it's really
really bad
what is not clear
is whether it is really really racial so
as we see here it's very patently clear
he doesn't think it's racist he doesn't
think it's there's any racially
aggravated reason but not only that ben
shapiro doesn't even believe that he was
murdered by the officer and that the
knee or neck which was fall intents and
purposes a blood choke yes a blood choke
for anyone who knows what blood chokes
ah was the cause for his death
it is not clear at this point that this
person died because he had a knee on the
back of his neck the very least the
officer should go to jail for assault
you would assume you see this is not
surprising it's not surprising like
someone like Ben Shapiro who has yes who
has a track record for his opposition to
black rights movements to civil rights
movements to Muslim rights movements to
say because when he was asked about the
disparity in wealth between white and
black people he says because it has
nothing to do with race and everything
you do it culture wait a minute what did
you say did you say it has nothing to do
with race and everything to do with
culture let's try and unpack that for a
second let's try and de motional eyes
this for a second let's try and
intellectualize this for a second let's
try and rationalize this for a second
are you saying are you insinuating are
you suggesting are you implying are you
trying to promote are you espousing are
you promulgating that two hundred and
forty seven years of racism of racist
slavery in America two hundred and forty
seven years of race-based slavery in
America followed with Jim Crow laws yes
Jim Crow laws that had no impact on the
contemporaneous reality that history has
no impact on the contemporaneous reality
the fact that slaves could not pass on
wealth to their offsprings to their
children to their grandchildren well
White's had the structural ability to do
so for all this years you don't think it
has a trickle-down economic effect you
must be deluded he must be absolutely
deluded no wonder why someone like
yourself cannot appreciate the plight
yes you cannot appreciate the plight of
the black man with a Muslim man with a
Mexican man because you're the record
for having said what about Arabs well
you said sure Israelis like to build
Arabs like to bomb crap and live in open
sewage that very statement is the
definition of racism well you think
you're better than someone because of
your race your racial group your group
you think your racial group is better
than other people other races Jews do X
Arabs do Y Arabs bombed things and and
live in sewers you said and Jews they
like to build things yeah really you
think that's a sensible statement to
generalize a community of three four
hundred million people many of which are
black because you can have a black arab
arabe meant economical Arabiya the arab
is the one who speaks in the arabic
language as Sudanese is an Arab there
are more Taney in Arabs there Mali and
Arabs there are Egyptian black Egyptian
Arabs so what all of these people like
to bomb things as well is that what
you're trying to say so how do I reverse
that statement now
and I say Jews like to bomb crap and and
live in sewers whereas Arabs like to
build things you think you wouldn't be
the first weasel whining weasel pathetic
to say that that's an anti-semitic
statement you'd cry let me tell you
something your time is up because all
the communities are waking up to your
nonsense the black communities are
waking up to it the Muslim communities
are waking up to it and although ethnic
miner isn't waking up to it the dominant
white communities are working up to it
we know that you have
gender boy you have an agenda and you
know what you are you are a scared man
just like you ran away you actually ran
away you ran away from a debate with
Andrew Neil so I think we're done here I
appreciate your time so you see how you
run away go emotional he got you the
knee he put you don't like being asked
questions you don't like being put on
the back foot I want to see the day
well you're man enough you're courageous
enough and you're strong enough to stop
debating these youngsters youngsters you
don't even give an equal opportunity to
speak they're not professors they're not
intellectuals they're not debaters
youngsters stop debating those
youngsters and getting your paid the
probably paid crowd to cheer against
them bully them and stand up to someone
like Andrew Neil from the Muslim
community or from the black community or
from the Mexican community or from any
other of the ethnic minorities that
you've been trivializing yes their
plight and trivializing their rights
give them equal opportunity and have a
debate with those I don't think you will
and I say to all communities who have
access to this man I say I think it's
about time to put the pressure on this
guy because his racism because anyone
who says those kinds of comments about
black people in obviously is is saying
clearly racist statements should put the
pressure on him how community should put
the pressure on him and those who follow
him and those like him we have to show
through media ability to do so so let's
do it now
what Sarah Malik Umar Akmal to lie you
or what I get
you